[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers
guten Abend hinein Wladimir Putin allein
zu Haus isoliert von der Welt im Kreml
das war Ziel des Westens nach dem
russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine die
Realität sieht anders aus und es zeigt
sich da eine neue Weltordnung deren
Folgen wir noch gar nicht komplett
ermessen können klar ist jetzt schon
unkompliziert wird sie nicht im
Gegenteil hi Jim ping und Vladimir Putin
China an der Seite Russlands das war
heute mehr als ein politisches treffen
das war eine Machtdemonstration zweier
Machthaber es könnte auch eine neue
Achse sein die im Westen für
Kopfschmerzen sorgen soll und wird
Sebastian eben berichtet
Wladimir Putins Auftritt heute in
Usbekistan soll eine Macht Demonstration
sein das Bild das der Kreml heute senden
will ist seht her Russland ist nicht
isoliert das Treffen mit Chinas
Präsident chienping ist dementsprechend
pompös inszeniert es ist das erste
Treffen der beiden seit Beginn der
sogenannten russischen spezialoperation
und wie schon im Januar werden die engen
Beziehungen auch heute bekräftigt
ein politischer Tandem zwischen Moskau
und Peking spielt eine zentrale Rolle um
den Frieden und regionale Stabilität
sicherzustellen
Usbekistan bietet für Russland und China
eine märchenhafte Kulisse für ihren
demonstrativen Schulterschluss die
Botschaft Richtung Westen wir können
auch ohne euch es sind zwei autoritäre
Staaten die beide keine Souveränität
abgeben wollen und die bei bestimmten
Themen Konkurrenz zu den USA miteinander
kooperieren und bei vielen anderen
Themen konkurrieren ja und in deren sich
ist das eine sehr ambivalente Beziehung
was die beiden haben und vieles was hier
an Demonstrationen von von Freundschaft
ist ist er ist eher oberflächlich
denn es ist nicht alles Gold was glänzt
es rumort in den ehemaligen
Sowjetrepubliken in dieser Woche kam es
zu schweren Kämpfen zwischen Armenien
und Aserbaidschan der von Russland
organisierte Frieden wackelt bedenklich
Scharmützel gibt es auch an der kirgisse
tadschikischen Grenze verliert Russland
die Kontrolle
in dieser Gemengelage reiste der
chinesische Präsident Chi gestern zum
ersten Mal seit zwei Jahren ins Ausland
ausgerechnet nach Kasachstan und das
noch vor seinem Zusammentreffen mit
Putin die Volksrepublik streckt ihre
Fühler aus in traditionell russisches
Einflussgebiet also wenn wir jetzt uns
Zentralasien anschauen wird China die
Chance nutzen das Russland geschwächt
ist um mehr Einfluss in den
zentralasiatischen Ländern zu bekommen
und über ähnliches werden wir eben auch
im Südkaukasus und in Osteuropa
beobachten und so steht Putin vor einem
Dilemma er will China als starken
Partner gegen den Westen und doch darf
der Einfluss der Volksrepublik nicht zu
groß werden wenn Russland seine Macht in
Zentralasien und im Kaukasus nicht
verlieren will
und 3000 Kilometer entfernt vom russisch
chinesischen Gipfel ein europäisch
ukrainisches treffen die
kommissionspräsidentin ist aus Brüssel
nach Kiew gereist passend zum Besuch hat
das EU-Parlament den Weg frei gemacht
für weitere Hilfsgelder aus Europa fünf
Milliarden Euro für den Betrieb des
Staates wie es heißt dieser Staat meldet
gerade militärische Erfolge im Kampf
gegen die russischen Truppen aber er
macht auch klar allein gratulierende
Worte dazu aus Europa reichen ihm nicht
und auch Ursula von der Leyen appelliert
heute von Kiew aus an Europa dem Land
auch westliche Kampfpanzer zu liefern
Katrin Eugendorf berichtet
das Koffein auf dem nauk Boulevard ist
ein szene-treffpunkt in hakif eines der
wenigen Cafés in der einst lebendigen
und kreativen Studentenstadt die noch
geöffnet sind was denken Sie hier von
Europa gibt ihnen die Aussicht dass ihr
Land der eu-beitreten könnte Hoffnung
die sind ein reiches Land und wir sind
im Prinzip bereit zu teilen wir sind
bereit der EU als gleichberechtigte
beizutreten aber als adoptierter Sohn
nein kaum wir wollen kein adoptiertes
Kind sein
selbstbewusst sehen sich vor allem die
jungen Ukrainer in der Studentenstadt
längst als Europäer auch wenn Russland
nur 30 km entfernt liegt und sie alle
russisch sprechen Mascha und Anna
studieren Wirtschaft und Medizin und Sie
möchten dass Ihr Land so schnell wie
möglich der EU Beitritt was erwarten sie
von Europa
dass wir eine Garantie erhalten dass wir
in den kommenden Jahren diesem
abscheulichen und wilden Staat der in
unser Land eingefallen ist unsere Häuser
zerstört und so viele Menschen getötet
hat nicht mehr nahe sein müssen
es sind eine Menge Erwartungen die die
Ukraine an Europa haben dass sich
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
für ihr Land stark gemacht hat wissen
viele allen voran Präsident wollladimir
selenski wie sehr er angesichts der
aktuellen Lage unter Druck steht ist ihm
anzusehen
wir brauchen für die Sicherheit
Luftabwehr ich bin sicher das ist keine
Überraschung für sie wir alle wissen
dass Luftabwehr und Raketen
Verteidigungssysteme wichtig sind
dennoch bin ich mir nicht sicher wie wir
das schnell lösen können ich weiß es ist
eine absolute Priorität
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen bekennt sich bei ihrem Besuch in
Kiew dazu längst nicht alle Wünsche
erfüllen zu können und so bleibt es vor
allem bei moralischer Unterstützung
ich kann Ihnen sagen dass sie ihre
europäischen Freunde an ihrer Seite
haben solange wie es nötig ist und dass
wir Freunde für immer sind
das mag glaubt man den Bildern für das
Verhältnis der beiden Politiker gelten
im Koffein in rakif machen sich die
beiden Freundinnen auf den Weg nach
Hause sie müssen sich beeilen gleich
beginnt die Ausgangssperre der Krieg
lässt sich im Osten der Ukraine immer
nur sehr kurz verdrängen
und damit sind wir in Deutschland wo der
Bundeskanzler das Wort Zeitenwende ja
selbst geprägt hat in Potsdam sprechen
Sie heute bereits von Epochenwende nicht
nur für Europa sondern für die ganze
Welt das gesamte ukrainische Volk ist
Preisträger einer Auszeichnung die heute
in Potsdam einer der Klitschkos
entgegennimmt stellvertretend für mehr
als 40 Millionen Menschen Thema im
Ostflügel des Schlosses Sanssouci ist
eine Welt voller Sorgen Katrin Lindner
ist dort
er wusste nicht ob er wirklich nach
Potsdam kommen kann Vladimir Klitschko
ist aus der Ukraine angereist um den
Preis persönlich entgegenzunehmen und zu
sprechen mit dem Kanzler es geht um viel
wir sind so weit gekommen dass nur mit
gut reden schafft man gar nichts
nur mit wirtschaftliche Sanktionen
schafft man schon aber nicht das was man
schaffen kann an der Frontlinie an der
Frontlinie wird entschieden mit
Überlegenheit der modernen Waffen um
genau das braucht die Ukraine wird es
bei einer Auszeichnung bleiben oder geht
der Kanzler an diesem Abend ein Stück
weiter Olaf Scholz hat immer wieder
betont dass er keine Alleingänge bei den
Waffenlieferungen machen wolle bisher
hat kein natoland Kampfpanzer westliche
Bauart in die Ukraine geliefert doch
genau das will die Ukraine Wladimir
Klitschko nutzt jede Minute wir helfen
mit
schweren militärischen Gerät mit Waffen
mit Munition mit der Ausbildung
ukrainischere Soldatinnen und Soldaten
denn ihr Kampf ist auch ein Kampf den
wir unterstützen
wir stehen daher fest an der Seite des
ukrainischen Volkes
ich bin mir sicher
Putin mit diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen
und so gibt es an diesem Abend einen
Preis und viele Worte
wie geht es weiter in der Ukraine und
was bringt ein Preis wenn ein Volk um
Kampfpanzer bittet europa muss sich
entscheiden so stimmen bei den
Teilnehmern in Potsdam
es ist eine Zeit für Entscheidung sind
wir bereit unseren Wohlstand zu opfern
um die Invasion zu stoppen und das
ukrainische Volk zu unterstützen
Kampfpanzer zu liefern Schützenpanzer zu
liefern ist eine gute Idee ich habe
schon Verständnis dafür dass man nicht
Alleingänge macht das würden wir ja auch
nicht gerne sehen wenn das die USA oder
Frankreich machen würden also gemeinsam
mit denen aber mit eine deutsche
Initiative die würde ich mir wünschen
die USA sollten klar machen dass wir
alles möglich machen was immer es auch
kostet dass Demokratie Autokratie
besiegt und Europa sicher ist
Sanssouci ohne Sorge heißt dieser Park
der Ort der Preisverleihung doch heute
wird er seinem Namen nicht gerecht
und wir bleiben noch beim Thema Ukraine
jetzt mit Johanna na Christian denn die
Ukraine wird weitere Waffen aus
Deutschland bekommen das verkündete
bundesverteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
zum Auftakt der bundeswehrtagung in
Berlin konkret geht es um zwei weitere
Raketenwerfer vom Typ Mars 2 inklusive
200 Raketen und um 50 gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge vom Typ Deko ein weiteres
wichtiges Thema das zweitägigen Treffens
ist der künftige Kurs der deutschen
Streitkräfte der Chef des
bundeswehrverbands wüstener beklagte
dass die Truppe in einem schlechten
Zustand sei von den geplanten 100
Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen sei noch
nichts angekommen
und mehr zu den Waffenlieferungen später
an unserem heute journal Update darin
ein Interview mit dem
CDU-Bundestagsabgeordneten und Oberst
ade Roderich Kiesewetter
das Europaparlament hat mit großer
Mehrheit für einen Bericht gestimmt der
Ungarn den Status als vollwertige
Demokratie abspricht Ungarn sei zu einer
Zitat
wahlautokratie geworden heißt es darin
dabei kritisierten die Abgeordneten auch
die EU selbst das Fehlen entschlossener
Maßnahmen habe zu einem Zerfall der
Demokratie der Rechtsstaatlichkeit und
der Grundrechte in Ungarn beigetragen
seit Monaten fordert das Parlament das
für Ungarn bestimmte EU-Mittel wegen
mutmaßlicher Verstöße gegen die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit zurückgehalten
werden
nach schweren Kämpfen zwischen
Aserbaidschan und Armenien haben sich
beide Länder gestern Abend auf eine
Waffenruhe geeinigt die Lage sei seit
dem verhältnismäßig ruhig erklärte das
armenische Verteidigungsministerium bei
den Auseinandersetzungen waren in den
vergangenen zwei Tagen nach offiziellen
Angaben mehr als 170 Soldaten getötet
worden beide Länder kämpfen seit
Jahrzehnten um die Region Bergkarabach
der deutsche Hausärzteverband fordert
abseits von Corona auch andere
Erkrankungen wieder mehr Aufmerksamkeit
zu schenken bei der bundesweiten
Impfkampagne müsse auch die
Grippeschutzimpfung im Fokus stehen
sagte der Vorsitzende des Hausärzte
Verbands Weigelt zum Auftakt des
hausärztetags in Berlin man rechne mit
einer deutlich heftigeren Grippewelle
als früher denn das Immunsystem sei nach
zwei Jahren mit niedrigen grippezahlen
nicht gut vorbereitet
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hat den
Holocaust Überlebenden im Rahmen des
Luxemburger Abkommens mit Israel weitere
Unterstützung versprochen auf der
Gedenkfeier zum 70 Jahrestag bezeichnete
Scholz das Abkommen als moralisches
Fundament unserer freiheitlichen
Demokratie
1952 verpflichtete sich die
Bundesregierung Entschädigungen an
Überlebende der Shoa zu zahlen
Deutschland will unter anderem weitere
58 Millionen Euro pro Jahr für
Pflegebedürftige Überlebende
bereitstellen
wer sein Schweden Bild von Astrid
Lindgren hat kann einerseits wunderbar
träumen vom blaubeerpflücken von
idyllischen roten Holzhäuschen in einem
Scheren Paradies und muss andererseits
Umdenken das Land steht vor einem
historischen Umbruch es brodelt im
Norden
jahrzehntelang war das ein toleranter
liberaler antiautoritärer Kurs der die
politische Agenda in Schweden bestimmt
hat nach dem Wahlkrimi am Wochenende und
dem sehr starken Abschneiden der
Rechtspopulisten hat die
Sozialdemokratin Magdalena anders schon
jetzt ihren Rücktritt eingereicht als
Ministerpräsidentin und damit den Weg
frei gemacht für eine mögliche
Regierungskoalition in der eine Partei
stärkste Kraft wäre die ihre Wurzeln hat
in der rechtsextremen Szene Heike Kruse
mit mehr
selbst die wahlkampfstände sehen ein
wenig nach polarby aus so niedlich und
friedlich
genau hier auf dem Land in Südschweden
haben die Rechtspopulisten ihre besten
Ergebnisse erzielt
Parteiführer jimmy orkeson hat mit den
Schweden Demokraten landesweit mehr als
20 Prozent der Stimmen geholt vor 20
Jahren waren es bei der Reichstagswahl
weniger als 2%. ein Grund für den Erfolg
gerade in der Provinz das Gefühl vieler
Menschen kein Gehör mehr zu finden
Währung die ich habe ist aber dass es
vor allem mit der Bandenkriminalität zu
tun hat das ist so viele Schießereien
gibt das gibt es nicht in Deutschland
der rechten Seite bei uns ist es
gelungen dass mit der Zuwanderung in
Verbindung zu bringen man sieht die
beiden Fragen als ein Problem
in keinem anderen Land in Europa sterben
im Verhältnis zur Bevölkerungszahl mehr
Menschen in Schussverletzungen als in
Schweden oft finden Schießereien wie
hier 2015 in Göteborg in Stadtvierteln
Stadt in denen viele Einwanderer Leben
doch nicht nur die Rechten Schweden
Demokraten verschärfen die
gesellschaftliche Diskussion der
schwedische Wohlfahrtsstaat erscheint
generell als ein Modell von gestern
opinionen die öffentliche Meinung und
die Einstellung der Parteien zu den
Fragen der Zuwanderung hat sich geändert
es herrscht ein anderes Klima nicht nur
durch die Schweden Demokraten auch die
anderen Parteien haben sich längst in
die rechtspopulistische Richtung gedreht
der Sozialdemokrat den Magdalena
Anderson hat allerdings ihre Äußerung
Schweden will keine Somali towns bei den
Wählern nichts genutzt die
Ministerpräsidentin überreichte den
Parlamentspräsidenten heute ihr
Rücktritt schreiben das rechte
Parteienbündnis hat das linke besiegt
mit hauchdünner Mehrheit vor der Wahl
hatte man sich im rechten Bündnis darauf
geeinigt dass Ulf Christa schon von dem
moderaten Ministerpräsident werden wird
dabei soll es bleiben obwohl die
moderaten weniger Stimmen als die
Schweden Demokraten bekamen
sind die Partei die das Land wieder
vereinen will wir werden alles tun um
die Unterstützung für Reformen zu
bekommen wir müssen auch die
Energiekrise bewältigen
im Fernsehen träumt der Chef der
Schweden Demokraten Jimmy orkeson
bereits von einem Ministerposten auch im
konservativen Parteienbündnis bislang
ein Tabu aber an einer
Regierungsbeteiligung der
Schwedendemokraten kommt wahrscheinlich
niemand vorbei das bullerbühland ist mit
waren ein großes Stück nach rechts
gerückt
die sogenannte konzertierte Aktion hat
nichts mit Musik zu tun und viel mit
Politik sie soll aus Sicht des
Bundeskanzlers zeigen wie eng Regierung
Arbeitgeber Gewerkschaften
zusammenstehen wenn es darum geht die
Kosten von Energie und Inflation
abzufedern Olaf Scholz hat dazu den
Vorschlag gemacht für besondere
Zahlungen werde der Staat keine Steuern
und Abgaben nehmen diese besonderen
Zahlungen erstmal leisten allerdings
müssten die Unternehmen und beim Geld
hört ja gerne mal die Freundschaft auf
Peter Böhmer jetzt über Ideen und
Befürchtungen in schwierigen Zeiten
die Funken sprühen in der Eisengießerei
quer in Bielefeld hier werden aus
Schrott tonnenschwere Bauteile gegossen
etwa für Kräne LKW oder Waggons der
Firmenchef blickte eigentlich nach
schweren corona-jahren optimistisch nach
vorn bis der Krieg kam Inflation
explodierende Energiekosten und nun 8%
Lohnforderung der Gewerkschaft für uns
bedeuten unsere Preise im nächsten Jahr
massivst unseren Kunden gegenüber
erhöhen müssen dazu kommt dass wir im
Moment das Damoklesschwert der sehr sehr
starken energiepreisverteuern für Strom
mit uns tragen müssen so dass wir also
nach jetzigem Stand unsere Preise
unseren Kunden gegenüber im nächsten
Jahr um mindestens 30 bis 35 Prozent
erhöhen müssen
285 Mitarbeiter im Familienunternehmen
alle haben Tariflohn am Ende über 50.000
Euro im Jahr aber was ist ein guter Lohn
Wert in diesen Zeiten es geht um Zukunft
ja wir werden ja bis jetzt gut bezahlt
aber es wird immer weniger vorher soll
der sage ich mal der Arbeitnehmer das
nehmen woher woher sollen die
Arbeitgeber das nehmen der
Wirtschaftskrise wird weg und weg was
ist zu tun eine Frage für die
konzertierte Aktion aus Politik
Unternehmen und Gewerkschaften das
zweite Treffen heute in Berlin doch
keine Antwort keine Fortschritte nur
Ankündigungen etwa beim Stichwort
Energiekosten wir wollen eine
Expertenkommission einsetzen die sehr
schnell schon im Oktober Ergebnisse
erzielt dafür haben wir Vertreter von
Unternehmen aus den Branchen gebeten
damit zu arbeiten wir haben
Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftler
gebeten das zu tun und es wurde über die
freiwillige steuerfreie pauschale aus
dem dritten Entlastungspaket gesprochen
die Arbeitnehmer elektrisieren dürfte
3000 Euro vom Arbeitgeber das wäre doch
was fürs heizkostenbudget
ihr die Gewerkschaften sind der
Auffassung dass wir weitere kurzfristige
Maßnahmen in diesem Jahr mit Blick auf
die kaufkraftstabilisierung brauchen das
bezieht sich zum einen auf das Angebot
die Aufforderung der Bundesregierung
zusätzliche Zahlungen von bis zu 3000
Euro steuerfrei zu ermöglichen mir ist
jedoch wichtig festzuhalten dass nicht
alle Unternehmen diese Einmalzahlungen
leisten können viele Betriebe stehen
gerade am wirtschaftlichen Abgrund für
Reinhard Wehr wäre die Pauschale kaum zu
leisten fast 900.000 Euro Gift für
seinen ausschwung er hofft auf
niedrigere industriestrompreise wie
anderswo in Europa sonst sei die
Existenz seines Unternehmens bedroht
jetzt was ganz anderes ein Milliardär
der seine Milliarden nicht mehr will ein
Milliardär der sagt hoffentlich führt
das mit zu einer neuen Form von
Kapitalismus bei der nicht am Ende ein
paar reiche stehen und viele arme ein
Milliardär der sagt jeder Milliardär ist
Zeichen für Politikversagen
das lässt aufhorchen das ist eine
Nachricht wert auf jeden Fall Hannah ja
es ist in der Tat eine
wirtschaftsmeldung der etwas anderen Art
der grün der milliardenschweren
Outdoor-Marke Patagonia hat sein
Unternehmen an gemeinnützige Stiftungen
verschenkt und die Gewinne sollen
künftig in den Klima- und Umweltschutz
fließen schon lange setzt der
patagonia-gründer auf Nachhaltigkeit in
seinem Unternehmen verwendet
beispielsweise ausschließlich
Biobaumwolle und ruft öffentlich dazu
auf Kleidung lieber zu flicken als neu
zu kaufen
jetzt dieser ohne Frage außergewöhnliche
schrittfragen Bethmann was steckt genau
dahinter und gibt es doch irgendeinen
Haken ist vielleicht zu viel gesagt da
meinen Teil der Gewinne der ist nicht
definiert wird auch künftig weiter ins
Unternehmen investiert und die Familie
behält Einfluss und Kontrolle über die
Stiftungen dennoch setzt Yvonne shinar
der nie Unternehmer werden wollte damit
ein dickes Ausrufezeichen für den
Klimaschutz der passionierte Bergsteiger
kam er zufällig zur Mode wollte zeigen
dass es auch nachhaltiger geht gründete
das outdoor-label Patagonia und spendet
bereits seit den 80ern ein Prozent
seines Umsatzes an Umweltorganisationen
der radikale Schritt jetzt konsequent
denn zwischen 83-Jährige shinade ist ein
Firma stetig wuchs obwohl erwachstum nie
als Ziel ausgegeben hat wollte Patagonia
nicht einfach verkaufen schon gar nicht
das Unternehmen an die Börse bringen der
Druck kurzfristiger Gewinne passe nicht
zur langfristigen Verantwortung der
Firmengründer kommentierte die
Stiftungslösung nun so die Erde ist ab
sofort unsere einzige anteilseignerin
war mit der Finanzelite ist er nie
geworden als er mitbekam dass Patagonia
fließwesten zum bevorzugten
Business-Outfit vieler Investmentbanker
wurden nahm er kurzerhand von Banken
keine Großbestellungen mehr an danke
Frank für diese Einschätzung
um nicht weniger als eine
Generalsanierung des maroden-bahnnetzes
ging es heute in Berlin beim
schienengipfel diese wird sich über
Jahre ziehen nun steht fest wo sie
starten soll ab Mitte Juli 2024 wird die
stark frequentierte Strecke zwischen
Frankfurt am Main und Mannheim für etwa
fünf Monate komplett gesperrt und
erneuert das betrifft auch 20 Bahnhöfe
danach sollen weitere
streckensanierungen folgen
zum Fußball genauer zur Europa liegt da
trafen am Abend Olympiakos Piräus und
der SC Freiburg aufeinander und am Ende
konnten die Freiburger jubeln sie
siegten mit 0 zu 3
er gilt als einer der besten Spieler die
der Tennissport je hervorgebracht hat
nach mehr als zwei Jahrzehnten auf der
profi-tour will Roger Federer seine
Karriere nächste Woche beenden das gab
der 41-Jährige Schweizer heute bekannt
als Grund nannte der ehemalige
Weltranglisten erste körperliche
Beschwerden in seiner Laufbahn hatte
Federer 20 Grand Slam und 103
atp-tour-titel gewonnen er war
Olympiasieger im Doppel und holte mit
der Schweiz den Davis Cup
berlin die Stadt der ewigen Baustellen
verzeichnet einen wirklich denkwürdigen
Fortschritt das Humboldt-Forum im wieder
errichteten Stadtschloss ist man kann
das wirklich so sagen fertig und öffnet
ab morgen endgültig alle Tore nach
jahrzehntelangen Debatten was denn nun
an diesem geschichtsträchtigen Ort
entstehen solle das Ergebnis Kunst und
Kultur aus aller Welt 20.000 weitere
Exponate zu sehen im jetzt eröffneten
Ostflügel des Schlosses eine spezielle
Ausstellung die mit leeren Vitrinen
beginnt und zwar ganz bewusst Stefan
Merseburger
[Musik]
echte Hingucker gibt es in Hülle und
Fülle
Häuser aus Papua-Neuguinea
buddhistische Wandmalereien in einem
rekonstruierten höhentempel von der
Seitenstraße
ein Modell der kambodschanischen
Tempelanlage am Chor Watt
und natürlich die benin-brosen
Werke die längst zu Symbolen für
Raubkunst geworden sind die gezeigten
Objekte sind Leihgaben sie gehören jetzt
Nigeria
mit den großen haben wir unser Wissen
bewahrt man hat sie uns geraubt und
damit Kenntnisse über unsere Kultur und
Geschichte die Branchen sind mehr als
bloße Objekte oder einfach Kunst
objetzt
es geht um Identität die meisten brancen
die bis vor kurzem deutschen Museen
gehörten werden zurückkehren nach Benin
City in Nigeria
zu haben ist wichtig so können die
jungen und die alten die noch mehr über
sie wissen sie endlich sehen darüber
können wir wirklich glücklich sein
ursprünglich geplant war hier 200
Bronzen zu zeigen doch dann kam die
Rückgabe jetzt sind es 40
Stimmen aus Nigeria kommen zu Wort
Geschichte Bedeutung und Raub der
Bronzen durch die britischen
Kolonialtruppen werden thematisiert auch
zeitgenössische Gunst ist zu sehen das
Konzept wurde gemeinsam mit
Museumsleuten aus Nigeria erarbeitet ich
würde sagen dass das hier auf der Höhe
der Zeit ist jedenfalls ist das
abgenommen wenn man so sagen will von
unserem Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus
Nigeria die Erzählung des narrativ der
neuen Ausstellung die Texte sind ja
abgestimmt wobei es jetzt hier keine
Zensur oder sowas gibt sein wir
entwickelt das gemeinsam
hier geht es nicht um Raubkunst sondern
um die Oma her ein indigenes Volk aus
Nebraska USA
Francis la Flash Omaha wurde von seinem
Vater auf ein christliches Internat
geschickt er studierte und kaufte als
Ethnologe im Auftrag des Berliner
Museums Ende des 19 Jahrhunderts diese
Sammlung er war überzeugt dass die Oma
hat den Rassismus der weißen nicht
überleben würden
es musste so viele Zeugnisse unserer
Kultur wie möglich retten um der Welt zu
sagen wir waren einmal hier
wir haben gelebt das Volk der Oma
und sie leben weiter für die Omaha ist
die Sammlung ein Schatz was tun wohin
damit das wollen die Berliner mit den
Omaha gemeinsam herausfinden
[Musik]
die dgb-chefin trifft gleich auf den
Chef des Bundesverbands der deutschen
Industrie moderiert von Maybrit Illner
die Kosten der Krise erst Preisschock
jetzt Pleitewelle Fragezeichen sehr
sehenswert nach uns und von uns allen
hier Danke für heute und gerne bis
morgen wir wünschen Ihnen einen
angenehmen Abend tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der
meteorologische Sommer ist ja nun vorbei
und auf der Nordheim ist Fähre war es
sehr warm 2022 der Sommer ist genauso
warm wie das Jahr 2020 und das war ein
Rekordjahr diese beiden Jahre sind also
auf gleicher Höhe und was Sie hier sehen
sind alle Sommer seit 1880 aufgereiht
und verbunden und wenn sie mal schauen
hier seit 1980 gibt es ja ein massiven
Anstieg in den Sommermonaten auf der
Nordhemisphäre die Erhitzung setzt sich
also fort und dieser Trend dafür gibt es
kaum eine Chance dass der nachlässt wir
schauen aufs Wetter und da gibt es von
Norden her kühle Luft mit dieser kühlen
Luft bilden sich shower und Gewitter
bereits in der kommenden nach dem Norden
Deutschlands und dazu gibt es kräftigen
Wind aus nordwestlichen Richtungen im
Westen und im Süden ebenfalls Regen
dazwischen aber trockener Abschnitte bei
tiefsten Temperaturen von 7 Grad im
Vogtland und im hessischen Bergland 14
Grad im Südwesten Deutschlands morgen im
Tagesverlauf bilden sich weitere Chance
Gewitter erstmal im Norden und dann auch
im Westen zum Nachmittag dann Richtung
Alpenrand dazwischen aber Bereiche mit
viel Sonnenschein und wenig Regen weil
höchsten Temperaturen von 18 Grad in der
Niederlausitz und 13 Grad am Alpenrand
und die nächsten Tage gehen mit schauen
und Gewittern weiter Samstag bei 8 bis
16 Grad am kühlsten damit ein schöner
Abend